if we you know aliens visit
in in thousands of years and humans are
long gone
something tells me that most of the
systems they find will be running
javascript i kind of think that if the
simulator if we're living in a
simulation it's raving it's written in
javascript
um you know for the longest time even
still
javascript didn't get any respect
and yet it runs so much of the world and
increasing number of the world is it
possible that
all everything will be written in
javascript one day so the engineering
under javascript is really pretty
phenomenal uh the
the systems that make javascript run as
fast as it does right now
are kind of miracles of modern
engineering in many ways
it does feel like
it is not an optimal language for all
the things that it's being used for or
an optimal distribution system to you to
build huge apps in something like this
uh without type systems and so on i'm
but i think for a lot of people it does
reasonably the necessary things it's
still a c flavored language it's still
uh you know abrasives in semicolon
language uh it's not hard for people to
be trained in javascript and then
understand the roots of where it came
from
i think garbage collection is
unequivocally a good thing for most
programs to be written in it's funny
that i still just this morning i was on
i was seeing a twitter thread of a bunch
of really senior game dev people arguing
about the virtues and costs of garbage
collection you will run into some people
that are top-notch programmers that just
say no this is literally not a good
thing because it makes you lazy yes that
it makes you not think about things and
i do disagree i think that
there is so much objective data on the
the vulnerabilities that have happened
in cnc plus plus programs sometimes
written by the best programmers in the
world it's like nobody is good enough to
avoid ever shooting themselves in the
foot with that you write enough c code
you're going to shoot yourself in the
foot and garbage collection is a very
great thing for the vast majority of
programs it's only when you get into the
tightest of real-time things that you
start saying it's like no the garbage
collection has more costs than it has
benefits for me there but that's not 99
plus percent of all the software in the
world
so javascript is not
terrible in those ways and
i am
and so much of programming is not the
language itself it's the infrastructure
around ever you know that surrounds it
all the libraries that you can get and
the different stuff that you can ways
you can deploy it i am the portability
that it gives you and javascript is
really strong on a lot of those things
where
for a long time and it still does if i
look at it the the web stack about
everything that has to go when you do
something really trivial in javascript
and it shows up on a web browser to kind
of x-ray through that and see everything
that has to happen for your one little
javascript statement to turn into
something visible in your web browser
it's
very very disquieting just the the depth
of that stack and the fact that so few
people can even comprehend all of the
levels that are going on there but it's
again i have to caution myself to not be
the in the good old days old man about
it because
clearly there's enormous value here the
world does run on javascript to a pretty
good approximation there and it's not
falling apart there's a bunch of scary
stuff where you look at console logs and
you just see all of these bad things
that are happening but it's still kind
of limping along and nobody really
notices
but
so much of my systems design and systems
analysis goes around you should
understand what the speed of light is
like what would be the best you could
possibly do here
and it sounds horrible but in a lot of
cases
you can be a thousand times off your
speed of light uh velocity for something
and it's still be okay and in fact it
can even sometimes still be the optimal
thing in a larger system standpoint
where there's a lot of things that you
don't want to have to parachute in
someone like me to go in and say make
this
this web page run a thousand times
faster you know make this web app into a
hardcore native application that starts
up in 37 milliseconds and everything
responds in less than one frame latency
that's just not necessary and if
somebody wants to go pay me millions of
dollars to do software like that when
they can take somebody right out of a
boot camp and say spin up an application
for this i often being efficient is not
really the best metric it's like there's
that applies in a lot of areas where
it's kind of interesting how a lot of
our appliances and everything are all
built around energy efficiency sometimes
at the expense of robustness in some
other ways or higher costs in other ways
where there's interesting things where
energy or electricity could become much
cheaper in a future world and that could
change our engineering trade-offs for
the way we build certain things where
you could throw away efficiency and
actually get more benefits that actually
matter that's one of my you know i
one of the directions i was considering
swerving into was nuclear energy when i
was kind of like what do i want to do
next it was either going to be i
cost-effective nuclear fission or
artificial general intelligence
and one of the one of my pet ideas there
is like you know people don't understand
how cheap nuclear fuel is and there
would be ways that i you could be a
quarter the efficiency or less but if it
wound up making your plant ten times
cheaper that could be a radical
innovation in something like that so
there's like some of these thoughts
around like direct fission
energy conversion fission fragment
conversion that you know maybe you build
something that doesn't require all the
steam turbines and everything even if it
winds up being less efficient so that
applies a lot in programming where
there's always it's always good to know
what you could do if you really sat down
and took it uh took it far because
sometimes there's discontinuities like
around user reaction times there are
some points where the difference between
operating in one second and 750
milliseconds uh not that huge you'll see
it in web page statistics but most of
the usability stuff not that great but
if you get down to 50 milliseconds then
all of a sudden this just feels amazing
you know it's just like doing your
bidding instantly rather than you're
giving it a command twiddling your
thumbs waiting for it to respond so
sometimes it's important to really
crunch hard to get over some threshold
but there are there are broad basins in
the value metric for lots of work where
it just doesn't pay to even go that
extra mile and there are craftsmen that
you know they just don't want to buy
that and more power to them you know if
somebody just wants to say no i'm going
to be i'm
my pride is in my work i'm never going
to do something that's not as good as i
could possibly make it i respect that
and sometimes i am that person but i try
to focus more on the larger value
picture and you do pick your battles and
you deploy your resources in the play
that's going to give you sort of the
best user value in the end well if you
look at the evolution of life on earth
as a kind of
programming effort
it's uh it seems like efficiency isn't
the thing that's being optimized for
like natural selection is very
inefficient but it kind of
uh adapts and through the process of
adaptations building more and more
complex systems they're more and more
intelligent the final result is kind of
pretty interesting and so i think of
javascript the same way
it's like this giant mess
that you know things naturally die off
if they don't work and they if they if
they're becoming useful to people they
kind of naturally live and then you
build this community large community of
people that are generating code and some
code is sticky some is not and nobody
knows
the
the inefficiencies or the efficiencies
or the breaking points like how reliable
this code is and you kind of just run it
assume it works and then get
unpleasantly surprised and that's very
kind of the evolutionary process so
that's a really good analogy and we can
go a lot of places with that where in
the earliest days of programming when
you had finite you could count the bytes
that you had to work on this you had all
the the kind of hackers playing code
golf to be one less instruction than the
other person's multiply routine to kind
of get through and and it was so
perfectly crafted it was a crystal piece
of artwork when you had a program
because there just were not that many
you couldn't afford to be lazy in
different ways and in many ways i see
that as akin to the symbolic ai work
where again if you did not have the
resources to just say well we're gonna
do billions and billions of programmable
weights here you have to turn it down
into something that is symbolic and
crafted like that but that's definitely
not the way
dna and life and
biological evolution and things work i
you know on the one hand it's
it's almost humbling how little
programming code is in our bodies you
know we've got a couple billion base
pairs and it's like this all fits on a
thumb drive for years now and then our
brains are even a smaller section of
that you've got maybe 50 megabytes and
this is not like shannon limit perfectly
uh information dense
uh
conveyances here it's like these are
messy codes you know they're broken up
into amino acids a lot of them don't do
important things or they do things in
very awkward ways but it is this process
of just accumulation on top of things
and you need
you need scale both you need scale force
or the population for that to work out
and in the early days in the 50s and 60s
the the kind of ancient era of computers
where you could count when they say like
when the internet started even in the
70s there were like 18 hosts or
something on it it was this small finite
number and you were still optimizing
everything to be as good as you possibly
could be but now it's billions and
billions of devices and everything going
on and you can have this very much
natural evolution going on where
lots of things are tried lots of things
are blowing up venture capitalists lose
their money
when a startup invested in the wrong
tech stack and things completely failed
or failed to scale
but you know but good things do come out
of it and it's interesting to see the
the memetic evolution of the way
different things happen like mentioning
hello world at the beginning it's funny
how some little thing like that where
everybody every programmer knows hello
world now and that was a completely
arbitrary sort of decision that just
came out of the dominance of unix and c
and early examples of things like that
so
millions of experiments are going on all
the time but some things do kind of rise
to the top and win the fitness war for
whether it's mind space or programming
techniques or anything like there's a
site on stack exchange called
code golf where people compete
to write the shortest possible program
for a particular task in all the
different kinds of languages and it's
really interesting to see
folks kind of um
they're masters of their craft
really play
with the limits of programming languages
it's really beautiful to see and across
all the different programming languages
you get to see
some of these weird programming
languages and mainstream ones by the
difference between python two and three
you get to see the difference between c
and c plus plus in java and you get to
see javascript all of that and
it's kind of
um
inspiring to see how much depth of
possibility there is within programming
languages that code golf kind of tasks
reveal
most of us if you do any kind of
programming you kind of do boring kind
of
very vanilla type of code that's the way
to build large systems but it's nice to
see that the possibility of creative
genius is still within those languages
it's
laden within those languages
you